géographie cinquième année les
différents systèmes économiques en
support à cette vidéo le syllabus de
géographie page 151 à 152 pour organiser
différentes activités économiques à
savoir produire distribué et consommé
les sociétés en plusieurs modalités
d'action dans les sociétés
traditionnelles
évidemment c'est une économie
traditionnelle basée comme leurs noms
l'indiquent sur la tradition dans les
sociétés modernes
il y a deux grands choix l'économie de
marché et l'économie planifiée et bien
sûr le mix des deux peut conduire à une
économie mixte dans une économie
traditionnelle le fonctionnement est
l'articulation des trois activités
économiques à savoir produire distribuer
consommer se base sur la tradition c'est
à dire qu'on fait toujours comme les
anciens ont fait il n'y a aucun
changement possible et d'ailleurs on ne
voit pas pourquoi il faudrait changer la
révolution industrielle va mener une
révolution économique
on va abandonner l'économie
traditionnelle pour passer aux économies
modernes avec deux grands choix
l'économie planifiée et le premier grand
choix que les sociétés peuvent adopter
les activités économiques dans
l'économie planifiée sont organisées par
l'état c'est l'état qui décide de
l'ensemble du fonctionnement de
l'économie
historiquement les états communistes ont
appliqué cette vision économique mais
dans la quasi majorité des cas ces
économies se sont effondrés démontrant
par cela leur inefficacité
dans une économie de marché les
activités économiques s'organise tout
selon les lois du marché
la liberté est la norme liberté
d'entreprendre tout le monde peut créer
une entreprise là où ils le souhaitent
et les consommateurs sont également
libres dans leur choix
la propriété privée est garantie les
capitaux et donc les investissements
sont principalement privé les facteurs
de production les machines et toutes les
infrastructures qui permettent de
produire appartiennent à des
propriétaires ou à des associations
d'actionnaires au sein des sociétés
anonymes les consommateurs décident
librement de l'utilisation de leurs
revenus ou en d'autres termes de la
demande qu'ils expriment de leur côté
les entreprises décident librement de ce
qu'elle ventes et des méthodes de
production utilisés c'est à dire de
l'offre qu'elle propose en eux tout
comme la libre entreprise est de mise
les entreprises sont mises en
concurrence ce qui est censé les
stimuler en les amenant à produire
efficacement à moindre coût tout en
proposant des prix compétitifs bénéfique
pour le consommateur final les trois
modalités d'organisation économique que
nous venons voir ne sont pas exemple
d'inconvénients l'économie
traditionnelle rend le progrès quasi
impossible si nous étions assez dans des
économies traditionnelles nous serions
encore touche à mourir de faim
actuellement et l'espérance de vie
n'excéderait pas certainement la
quarantaine d'années dans l'économie
planifiée le progrès possible mais c'est
relativement inefficace faut beaucoup de
moyens finalement pour un minimum
d'individus et un minimum de confort
enfin dans l'économie de marché
évidemment aller beaucoup plus efficace
elle permet également le produit le
progrès mais al abandonne tout ce qui
n'est pas rentable
c'est à dire que si vous invitez un
village perdu du fin fond des ardennes
il est très peu probable que l'économie
de marché vous permettre d'accéder à
tous les biens dont vous avez besoin
elle génère aussi un certain nombre
d'inégalités sociales et un certain
nombre de crises comme l'a encore montré
la crise de 2009
enfin il ya des externalités négatives
une externalité c'est quelque chose qui
est une conséquence finalement
de l'échangé économique la pollution les
dépressions qui peuvent survenir au sein
d'une population de travailleurs d'une
entreprise sont des exemples
d'externalités négatives l'économie
mixte permet de minimiser les défauts
des économies planifiées de l'économie
de marché la base de l'économie et le
marché mais celui ci est corrigée par
l'état qui va redistribuer les richesses
par l'impôt et les taxes afin de limiter
les inégalités qui va financer la
production de biens et de services
utiles pour l'ensemble de la société qui
va garantir la concurrence sur les
marchés et éviter qu'ils et l'entente
entre des entreprises qu'ils soient
néfastes au final pour le consommateur
l'état va garantir aussi les libertés
fondamentales à la libre entreprise et
la concurrence ils valent à lutter
contre les externalités en légiférant
contre la pollution contre les émissions
de dioxyde de carbone les nuisances
sonores olfactives le bien-être au
travail et en même temps l'état va
permettre de résister aux crises
économiques et aux crises monétaires si
l'état n'était pas venu au secours de
certaines banques en 2009 on pourrait
légitimement penser que la situation
serait beaucoup plus catastrophique
qu'elle n'a été le rôle de l'état est
donc très important car sans lui une
économie de marché ne peut fonctionner
et je ne peux terminer cet exposé en
citant john solomon qui dit nous dit que
l'idée que l'intervention de l'état
puisse servir à corriger les diverses
défaillances du marché est un concept
fondamental de la théorie économique on
notera cependant que les gouvernements
ne sont pas parfaits et que leurs
actions peuvent engendrer des
conséquences aussi bien des fastes que
bénéfique